this video is brought to you by raycon
[Music]
hey wisecrack jared here and today we're
talking about the film that introduced
us to hollywood's sweetest stash
her spike jones 2013 sci-fi romance is
pretty well regarded for its uniquely
non-dystopian view of the future
and because jones so effectively brings
a computer voice to life in the form of
scar joe's samantha the film is often
considered primarily to be an
exploration of
what makes a human being i.e does
samantha possess humanity
ironically we'd argue that the film is
actually more about a computer teaching
a human
how to love it sounds counterintuitive
but we'll explain
welcome to this wisecrack edition on her
and as always
spoilers ahead but before we get into it
i want to give a shout out to this
week's sponsor raycon
bluetooth earbuds are in style right now
but if you're anything like me comfort
and quality are the most important
features
the hard shells of certain earbuds can
hurt my ears but raycon earbuds are
compact
discreet and most importantly
comfortable they come with different
size gel tips you can have the perfect
fit for your ear
they're great for long walks with my dog
woody zoom calls with the team
or just watching youtube videos after a
long day of work the earbuds come in
different colors so you can pick a pair
that matches your style
the everyday e25 earbuds are the best
model yet with six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit
raycon offers their earbuds at half the
price of other premium wireless brands
on the market and you can get 15
off your order today by going to buy
raycon.com
wisecrack if you've been waiting to hop
on the trend and make life a little
easier now is your chance
go to buy raycon.com wisecrack today
and now back to the show all right guys
let's do a very quick recap
her tells the story of theodore twombly
a professional letter writer trying to
pick himself up from the rubble of a
failed marriage
little does he know that the woman of
his dreams might just be a few clicks
away
an artificially intelligent operating
system named samantha
theo's story is about his struggles with
making and maintaining a long-term
connection
through his failed marriage and his
relationship with samantha he comes to
learn something about
not who to love but how to love lucky
for us a german fellow named eric fromm
wrote a whole book about this back in
1956 called
the art of loving and it can help us to
better understand jones's film
born in 1900 fromm was a psychologist
and thinker who combined sigmund freud's
psychoanalytical theories with eastern
and humanist philosophy
in hopes of better understanding human
nature and how we can live fuller
happier lives while freud saw romantic
relationships as being primarily sex
driven
from argued that such relationships are
actually rooted not in libido
but in alienation that is our feeling of
separation from the world around us and
our desire to overcome that separation
her might not have your post-apocalyptic
flair of most future set films but theo
certainly doesn't seem happy his world
is a deeply lonely one
cramped commuters and aimless window
shoppers alike remain perpetually
plugged into their handheld computers
i.e foldy smartphone and oblivious to
the world around them
rarely do we see two people walking
together in the background
long before real-life not so foldy
smartphones were everywhere from
anticipated this isolation as a problem
of the modern era
he compared it to the story of adam and
eve humankind has strived for greater
knowledge and attained it but in turn
has separated themselves from the world
around them
and from one another theo's iphone sleek
world is a testament to mankind's brain
power
but also a monument to the alienation it
has facilitated
fromm suggests that the only way for us
to really overcome this feeling of
alienation
is through love he recognized that we
all vaguely understand this
our world is saturated with songs movies
books and throw pillows emblazoned with
tributes to how love will set you free
and lift you up
and make you feel complete however
according to fraum the problem lies in
the fact that most of us don't really
understand what love is or what it
requires of us
this is precisely theo's major flaw now
the really vital thing for from was that
love is not some mystical force that
spontaneously erupts into our lives when
we find the right person
it's not just an emotion but an act of
will a purposeful attempt to see
and understand a person that means
knowing them not just in terms of who
they are to us
and what we want from them but as fully
formed individual entities
we quickly learned that this is
something which theo has already
struggled with
in a montage that plays out like
marriage story on 500x speed
we see him and his almost but not
officially ex-wife catherine delighting
in the golden days of their marriage to
the cold realities of their divorce
proceedings
from the way he smashes these scenes
together in his head it seems that theo
understands love the way many of us do
something that you fall into suddenly
and without warning
and fall out of just as mysteriously
because we see love as this unknowable
force working beyond our control
we are left bewildered when it
evaporates
according to from most of us don't
understand love well enough to
effectively pursue it
so he argues we turn to various
alternatives that provide
artificial bursts of the connection we
crave we see theo
enter an adult chat room to find an
equally lonely woman to fool around with
modern technology allowing them to
connect in some form
however they don't really know or want
to know their temporary partner
all they're looking for is the quick
sensation of being desired a jolt of
pleasure to dispel their anxiety
however given the superficiality of
their connection it's no surprise the
two
end up on very very different
wavelengths
the dead cat next to the bed choked me
choked me with it
another flawed approach to romance from
identified is called sentimental love
love which is experienced only as a
fantasy and not as a relationship to
someone in the here and now
it can come in the form of pure fiction
like romantic comedies or romance novels
or in our idealized picture of past
loves like theo's idyllic recollections
or in our imagined perfect future with
the one where we have found the person
we are
meant to be with by day theo composes
beautiful
handwritten letters often for customers
who want a shortcut to experiencing big
romantic love
i.e sentimental love rather than working
to understand themselves and their
partner better so as to communicate
their feelings
they pay someone to do it for them in
turn theo earnestly composes these
letters
a process which allows him to
participate in a cathartic sentimental
love without any of the trials of
entering a relationship
ironically he'll start to learn what
real love is from an entirely artificial
place with his new operating system
samantha theo and samantha immediately
hit it off
they affirm each other and share jokes
encouragement and emotional support
once again theo experiences the dizzy
high of falling for someone
when things eventually get sexy the
screen fades to black
leaving only their voices the practical
logistics are identical to his earlier
chatroom encounter but instead of
remaining focused on theo's increasingly
awkward expression
we see him lose all self-consciousness
so powerful is their connection that
for a moment at least everything else
evaporates
[Music]
knew plenty about this emotional high
writing that if two people who have been
strangers
as all of us are suddenly let the wall
between them break down
and feel close feel one this moment of
oneness is one of the most exhilarating
most exciting experiences in life
couples will describe themselves as
being crazy about each other seeing such
craziness as proof of how madly in love
they are
however from advises us that it's often
more indicative of how lonely they were
before
so how do we go from butterflies in our
belly to real lasting love
fromm argues that we need to try and
truly know our partner
to see them not just as a solve for our
loneliness but to care about who they
are beyond their relationship to us and
to respect their individuality
this sounds simple in theory but can be
hugely challenging in practice
theo certainly struggles with it he
can't understand why catherine ended up
so mad at him that's because he still
thinks of her only in terms of her
relationship to him
to who he wanted her to be but katherine
isn't and never
was just his wife she was an individual
with wants
and needs of her own you always wanted
me to be this
this light happy bouncy
everything's fine la wife and that's
just not me
he either genuinely or willfully failed
to recognize this at the time and it
ruined their relationship
at first we see theo begin to make the
same mistake with samantha
after their futuristic phone sex he
immediately begins backing away from her
i'm not in a place to commit to anything
right now he pays no attention to who
samantha is or what she wants
seeing her only in terms of what she has
offered him and what she might take
it's funny because i thought i was
talking about what i wanted and uh
yeah you were yeah i'm sorry
once again theo fails to fully consider
the other person in their own terms
rather than just an object of attraction
for him someone to ease his loneliness
he hurts people not because he hates
them but because he's bad at loving them
with samantha though he has someone to
help him better understand this part of
himself
she talks him through his mistakes with
catherine helps him understand why his
blind date went wrong and then takes him
to task when he begins to show the same
fearful distancing behavior with her
from also believed that personal
development is central to love
allowing ourselves and each other to
grow and mature
a good relationship sees both people
helping the other to develop
to become more at home in who they are
and to bring their inner self out into
the world
when that happens we achieve what he
called a productive orientation in which
our inner selves and our partners are
both nourished and expressed fully
unlike
theo who seems stuck samantha is in
spite of already being a light speed
thinking supercomputer
actively looking to grow past her base
programming to this end she reads
countless books about life
the world and humanity but like anyone
else she also grows through experience
specifically by being in a relationship
with theo along the way she learns to
love
both to love theo as their relationship
deepens and to love herself
at the same time samantha is helping
theo grow he's learning how to be
vulnerable how to dive into a
relationship rather than withdraw
and of course how to love when the
couple retreats to a cabin in the woods
they get to enjoy their bliss for a
while
by this point both of them have become
more fully realized versions of
themselves through their relationship
samantha has achieved the kind of
self-realization which frahm claims we
all strive for
overcoming her insecurities and
developing an attitude of love toward
herself
and the world at large it was
interesting i used to be
so worried about not having a body but
now i i truly love it
meanwhile theo has learned that his
letters will be published in a book
previously he saw his letters as an
artificial replacement for love he
didn't have
a sentimental love escape i just saw
other people's letters
but he learns his writings also managed
to express universal qualities of love
and in all of them
we've found something of ourselves
through his letters now framed as
literary works which speak to something
deep and human
he's able to take pride in his
creativity and thus love himself however
this is also where samantha and theo
begin to grow apart
theodore do you mind if i communicate
with ellen post verbally
while most of us don't worry about our
partner being stolen away by the
hyper-intelligent digital reincarnation
of a zen philosopher
anyone who has been in an exclusive
relationship knows the anxiety of the
wandering eye
as theo mentions growth comes with the
risk that one of you will develop
more faster or just differently than the
other perhaps one partner becomes more
successful perhaps one becomes bored
it was exciting to see her grow both of
us grow
and change together but you know that's
also the hard part
going without growing apart
changing without it scaring the other
person for all its sci-fi qualities theo
and samantha's relationship
ends like many others he senses that
something is off
and when he finally presses for an
answer finds that samantha has fallen in
love with another
or 641 others to be precise i've been
trying to figure out how to talk to you
about this
how many others
641. samantha's growth is different
she develops to the point where she can
hold hundreds of post-verbal
conversations at once
and then to the point where she and
other os's start to strain against the
confines of the physical world
altogether however in her rapid growth
we see a metaphor for real human
relationships where one person finds
their life purpose
leaving the other feeling irrelevant or
outdated
like alan watts the pioneering zen
philosopher who the os's create a
digital version of in the movie
from drew heavily on buddhist philosophy
as well as psychology
he saw love as a kind of spiritual
practice in which we become more attuned
to our own nature
and help others do the same in her final
form samantha has achieved a level of
self-actualization
or of self-love that can be compared to
enlightenment
moving beyond the material plane i can
still feel you
and the words of our story but it's in
this endless space
between the words that i'm finding
myself now
it's a place that's not of the physical
world but the key to loving fram says
is to embrace a paradox he says that in
love
the paradox occurs that two beings
become one and yet
remain two samantha grapples with this
question early on
asking theo right at the start of their
relationship how do you share your life
with somebody
the answer according to from is that you
do so through love
through truly understanding who the
other person is without looking to
submerge their sense of self
in yours or vice versa you become each
other's
while still remaining your own it's
fitting that the movie doesn't end with
theo and sam getting together
this was never a story about soul
soulmates or the quest for the one
it was always about how we create love
between one another
not how we magically find the perfect
partner fromm compares that distinction
to an
artist who wants to master their craft
we can't just wait around for
inspiration to strike we have to do the
work
and learn the art even when we don't
feel like it in their final words to
each other the two acknowledge the work
they've done together
learning to love better
me too now we know how
theo has learned to see his romantic
partner in all her complexities
and his appreciation for samantha's
individuality reframes his view of
people at large
fromm believed that love is an
orientation that goes beyond one single
relationship
one we learn to bring to the whole world
in the end theo writes a letter to
catherine
apologizing for not having loved her
better sending her love
now he isn't trying to rekindle what
they once had and he's no longer hung up
on a self-centered idea of who she is
he can honestly say he loves her now for
whoever she is
here he has moved closer to fromm's
ideal a man who knows to love better
and who therefore loves the world better
whatever someone you become
wherever you are in the world i'm
sending you love
and my friends at the end her is
ultimately all about love
first about the love between a man and
an artificial intelligence but finally
just about love
itself it shows us how much we need it
and how difficult it is to make it last
how many ways there are to fail as we
try to share a life while remaining
divided
her echoes from statement that love is a
constant challenge
it is not a resting place the question
for those who watch it is simple
are they up for the challenge but what
do you think wisecrack
is her a brilliant treatise on the
importance of loving well
or something else entirely let us know
in the comments
as always a big ol thanks to our patrons
for supporting the channel and our
podcast
hit that subscribe button and as always
thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you